نحن نقصف أفقر
دولة في العالم والتي
كانت تحت حصار إنساني، كانت هناك مجاعة، لقد
هلك هؤلاء الناس ونحن
نقصفهم
لأن اثنين من الرجال في زورق
لدعم الفلسطينيين الذين
يواجهون  الإبادة الجماعية المرتكبة ضدهم،
إنهم يعترضون على ذلك ونحن
نقصفهم هيا الآن، أعني أن هذا
مجرد عالم مجنون بالنسبة لنا حتى أن
نعتقد أنني آسف جدًا لتأخر طرود أمازون الخاصة بك،
أنا حقًا أتمنى أن
أعود  ذات مرة، لكنك تعلم أن رجال الإبادة الجماعية يرتكبون إبادة جماعية،
هناك أمتان تموتان يوميًا
في غزة الآن، لقد مرت 109 أيام
على الصراع الذي أدت فيه
الأزمة الإنسانية إلى مقتل 5,000 شخص في غزة
الآن، وهناك أكثر من 60,000
جريح دون إمكانية الحصول على الغذاء  مساعدات المياه،
كيف نجرؤ على إجراء محادثة حول
التجارة عندما يكون هناك أطفال
يعالجون الآن دون مخدر،
هناك أشياء تتطلب منا أن
نجعلهم يمتلكون الاقتصاد العالمي،
الأسواق العالمية رهينة جيدة لهم، جيدة لهم،
أوقفوا إطلاق النار الآن، أوقفوا إطلاق النار الآن نحن  '
سيتعين علينا اه ترك الأمر اه هناك
ولكن
أم